Лісабон - це красень у затоці Тежу.
Старе морське місто, збудоване на семи пагорбах.
Це столиця та культурний центр Португалії.
Щороку його відвідують близько шести мільйонів туристів з усього світу.
Тож така велика подія, як Євробачення,
для півмільйона мешканців Лісабона не є проблемою.
Лісабон - найкраще місто для Євробачення.
Ми маємо сонце, чудову їжу і прекрасних людей!
Лісабон - фантастичне місто, і музика - його невід'ємна частина!
Артисти з 43-х країн світу хочуть не лише виступити тут,
але й відчути стиль життя міста.
Німеччину на конкурсі представляє Міхаель Шульте.
Разом із німецькою делегацією він відвідує
перлини Лісабона. Зокрема, Беленську вежу.
Це мультикультуральна подія, тут зібралися представники багатьох країн.
У "Євробаченні" класно те, що тут абсолютно не має значення,
з якої країни ви приїхали, хто ви, якої статі.
Всі щасливі тут разом і чудово проводять час.
Лісабон, як старе морське місто, розстилає синій килим
для пісенного конкурсу на березі Тежу,
перед будівлею Музею мистецтва, архітектури та техніки.
Саме тут відбулося офіційне відкриття музичного конкурсу.
Португалія - країна, яка дійсно полюбляє гостей.
Ми відкриті для світу, у нас немає кордонів і ми хочемо, щоб саме так було у світі.
Пам'ятник першовідкривачам і Роза вітрів у вигляді мозаїки.
600-річну морську традицію видно повсюди.
Символи цьогорічного "Євробачення"
також перегукуються з морськими мотивами.
Океани означають для нас все, у цій символіці –
спосіб життя з різними культурами, віруваннями, кольорами і расами.
Саме це усе мав означати наш слоган : «Усі на борт!».
Інклюзивний, імперативний і морський водночас.
Це означає все для нас!
За подіями на сцені "Євробачення" стежитимуть 200 мільйонів глядачів з усього світу.
Тут також простежується морська тематика.
Сцену створив німецький дизайнер Флоріан Відер.
Існує насправді три елементи. Це навігація.
Навігацію можна побачити у вигляді цих трьох арок,
які також присутні в португальському прапорі.
Друге  - це суднобудівництво. Це відображається
в цих хвилях або ребрах, які також відомі з класичного суднобудівництва.
І, нарешті, просто море і вода, це форма конструкції на задньому плані.
На Торговельній площі в центрі Лісабона
розміщене містечко "Євробачення".
Тут часто можна бачити цьогорічних кандидатів
пісенного конкурсу, як наприклад, представницю Португалії Клаудію Паскаль.
Це гарний спосіб познайомитися з Європою!
Я з чудесної країни Канади і я тут, в Лісабоні, через Євробачення!
Але далеко від усього цього галасу конкурсу,
в розважальному районі Барріо-Альто,
справжня мелодія міста звучить незмінно: це фадо.